i completed this course in 2019 and got
my first official job immediately after
i have changed a couple of jobs since
then and i currently work as a software
developer at green tech visionary
enterprise in nigeria i have been here
for almost two years now and i really
enjoy my work
do you ever get this feeling that i
really like what i'm doing right now but
i can do much better in life
well that is what happened to me when i
started my software internship as a
software developer right after college
in 2018. i dealt with mobile development
and cloud development but was curious
about devops hence i decided to up-skill
myself and do more
hi my name is abdullah ahmad i come from
nigeria i have done the devops architect
masters program from simply learn
my job role involves working in the
devops domain and indulging in the cloud
and mobile hybrid development i'm also
getting regular freelance work
i also learned agile methodology while
completing this course
and i must say it has helped me a lot
because of this i can plan my projects
properly now and even save a lot of time
for myself or my freelance projects i
have even started planning and
scheduling my day-to-day activities
using this methodology which has helped
me a lot
talking about scheduling i really liked
the way our live classes were scheduled
i could find a specific
schedule for myself or even reschedule
the live classes if we missed any the
trainers were super helpful and
supportive as well they answered all the
questions and whenever i raised any
tickets or queries they were answered
very quickly
and of course there are those super
in-depth self-study modules basically i
really enjoyed learning with simply
learn
well i'm at a good place in my life and
i like the work that i'm doing but
eventually in the near future i would
like to move abroad and work at some big
firm
and i'm sure the skills acquired while
taking this course will play a major
role in doing so keep growing and
upskilling